Okay.
Um,
and I'm just going to briefly introduce it and then leave 48 minutes for you to
win.
He has to say it will get a graduate of this college in [inaudible] 78,
class of 78
with a
professional career in art history.
Uh,
and,
and that's not an easy combination and he does it with grace and with,
uh,
he liked Sharon.
Oscar is a stand out in the school of Management Mba program,
Ivy direct,
uh,
the International Center for finance.
Uh,
and is the capitalist city.
I'm a gender switch.
We'll see,
uh,
in his slides and in his analysis is a truly impression.
Please help me.
Welcome.
We'll get it.
Okay.
Well thanks a lot for the introduction and,
uh,
I'm,
I was thrilled with the idea of this course.
So,
um,
was really looking forward as Doug was describing the idea of the,
uh,
of the course and,
um,
his plans for it and what you all have been doing.
It seems like a fantastic,
uh,
thing.
So,
uh,
the question in my mind was,
what could I add today that would be of interest to you?
And I thought what I would do is focus a little bit on the historical
backgrounds to the current prices.
I know you've been doing some reading about the,
uh,
the current crisis and its relationship to ideas of capitalism and so forth.
I thought a little bit of historical foundation would be a good thing to,
to,
to lead off with and,
and uh,
give you an idea of how old these financial crises are.
This is a cuneiform tablet from the old Babylonian period,
roughly 1600 BC.
It's,
um,
it's,
uh,
a loan so that,
it was,
uh,
created with the terms of the loan on one side and,
and,
and typically,
although you can't see it from this side,
you'll have people that are witnesses to the loan on the other side.
So Deb has been around for a long time.
And one interesting feature about debt is that usually when you,
um,
if you are a lender,
you like to have some collateral,
the collateral for debts in this time period,
often we're human capital.
In other words,
if you defaulted on your loan,
the borrower could seize you for three years.
And your family and make it,
and you'd have to work loan off.
So,
uh,
that,
um,
that sort of debt slavery,
was something that began quite early in,
in a human culture.
You had when you had with the debt slavery,
there'll be periods when people would get themselves into a terrible mess and,
uh,
let's say crops failed and lots of farmers wouldn't be able to pay off their
loans.
You'd have lots of the society in deep debt.
And,
um,
the,
uh,
king periodically would decree all debts no and void.
So wiping the slate clean.
So here is a,
here's a,
a,
a fragment of an edict by Sam [inaudible] Luna,
who was the son of Hammurabi,
um,
who by the way lived in the city,
that,
uh,
Gail has had a longtime expedition to excavate,
called,
uh,
tell lay lawn.
Um,
anyway,
this is releasing everybody from,
uh,
from,
from bankruptcy in the form of debt slavery.
But the issue there of course is where do you draw the line?
Which debts do you release?
And,
and,
and if you just want to take people out of slavery,
but where you want to maintain a financial system,
how do you,
how do you differentiate?
Uh,
that's the solution of that problem?
at least in the,
from the view of,
of,
uh,
writers in antiquity,
particularly,
uh,
Aristotle who wrote about Salon,
um,
comes in the form of a,
of another major debt crisis.
Um,
when Sala NovaThreads became the,
uh,
auto park or whatever you want to call it,
the leader of Athens,
it was about 600 BC or so,
somewhere in that timeframe.
And he was brought in because there was a terrible crisis,
uh,
much like the crises in the Middle East.
There was a period when when a Athenian citizens had been seized a four debts
and these were debts and typically by farmers,
and then they'd been sold off outside of Athens and just sell them off shores in
export,
the export these debt slaves.
And it created terrible crisis.
So,
um,
Salam was from a wealthy family.
Uh,
he was elected by the sort of the rich people in Athens.
They thought that he would stand up for property rights and,
uh,
he wouldn't let the financial system go to hell just because of the pain
inflicted on the,
on the poor,
uh,
portion of society.
Um,
what he did made nobody happy.
He said,
we're gonna preserve property rights.
We're going to preserve the right to contract,
but we only thing we're going to forbid is the right to sell yourself into
slavery.
So he drew the line,
um,
at that,
at that a debt slavery point.
And,
um,
ever afterwards,
people,
uh,
Athenians would look at him.
He sort of was like the George Washington of Athens in 200 years later,
people would write about this moment in time when he,
he,
um,
he made the differentiation between the financial system and the,
and the system of,
of human slavery.
It wasn't,
not to say that slaves didn't exist,
but the ability to contract on your,
on your freedom,
uh,
was not allowed after,
after a solid,
I'm gonna skip forward through a lot of exciting financial history.
Those of you that,
like,
that kind of stuff might consider taking.
I,
I teach a course seminar,
senior seminar,
financial history,
uh,
in the spring.
So,
um,
if you are interested in those topics,
love to have you participate,
I'm going to skip forward to our debt crisis because,
uh,
I worry,
I stay up late nights worrying that we're getting ourselves back into a debt
slavery situation.
Um,
and,
uh,
the recent,
code that we've,
we've,
uh,
the bankruptcy code has made it hard for people to shift off their debts or
shake off their debts,
which is the term that solid used a solid use.
It was called Sys arc thorough or something like this as shaking off like an
earthquake.
Um,
but I'm going to skip forward to 1892 and have you read this quote because it,
it,
it lets you have some sense of where the policy for a real estate mortgage
lending in the United States might have come from.
Um,
the occasion for this was a big festive dinner.
might've been at Delmonico's restaurant,
I'm not sure exactly where,
I don't think it says here,
but in New York and a bunch of guys,
uh,
in the real estate business in New York were getting together and they're really
kicking off a and attempt to create a real estate exchange in New York City.
And the exchange,
um,
there had been as something like a real estate exchange where properties were
listed in brokers,
uh,
um,
were admitted and so forth.
The idea that they were coming to was that they needed an exchange for real
estate securities.
Like real estate securities that we have now are,
are,
um,
a lot of them are things like,
oh,
you've heard lots about Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac and,
and uh,
and sub prime loans and,
um,
uh,
commercial mortgage backed securities and things like that.
Well,
these guys were thinking about setting up an exchange to trade,
um,
uh,
debt.
Uh,
maybe some equity to actually in New York in New York would be the center of
real estate.
I'm trading.
What were they going to trade?
Well,
here's a picture,
just a piece of a bond.
Um,
uh,
that,
have the kind they were going to trade.
These things are incredibly beautiful.
The new,
uh,
the U s bank note company made bonds for made stocks and bonds and money for all
the countries in the world.
And,
uh,
they had incredibly detailed filigrees and,
and uh,
and these beautiful motifs and so forth.
It wasn't to make these things more attractive to customers.
All of this detail was really to prevent counterfeiting because,
uh,
you,
you know,
if you could rep,
if you could counterfeit a bond like this,
you could take it in and,
um,
and,
and uh,
you can take it in and get coupons.
So what's this bond?
It's a $500 bond.
It's issued to finance something called 44 Wall Street Corporation.
Um,
and it's the Manhattan company building.
So 44 Wall Street is still a building in Manhattan.
I don't know if anybody here might've worked there during the summer.
Uh,
but,
um,
there was a corporation that was set up to build and operate one single building
and there were some equity capital in the corporation and there were some debt
in the corporation.
The debt was issued to the public in bonds.
So,
um,
uh,
you,
you and I could go out and we could buy these bonds and then the coupons,
the money that would come in from the bonds is money that would come in based
upon the rents are we're being paid by people that leased space in this 44 Wall
Street building.
So this is a fairly extraordinary kind of security,
just particularly because we don't have security's like this anymore.
I mean,
there are some bonds that have been issued against buildings.
Um,
and,
uh,
I'm thinking now of um,
things like,
uh,
in London you have this vast project in,
in the,
uh,
Canary Wharf and that was financed with some really interesting debt,
but one to one building to,
to bond.
Really,
we don't have a,
in the modern day,
this one,
by the way,
it was issued one month or so,
right?
Right after a few,
not long after the great crash.
Here's a little bit about this market.
The market was nothing much.
This is a,
this is the total cumulated amount of outstanding debt based on the face value.
So the face value of that removes $500.
Um,
you'd multiply that times the total number of bonds.
you add all of those bonds that existed up in this,
these are the numbers.
You're getting 100 million,
200 million,
so on.
So you see that even in 1913,
there were some of these bonds being issued.
Um,
and um,
then,
uh,
there are two companies here that we're tracking.
New York title and Mortgage Company and Lawyers,
lawyers,
mortgage company.
These two companies actually served as guarantors for debt in particular.
Actually what they would do,
the about eight companies got together or didn't get together,
but eight companies offered a service.
They would take a residential mortgage,
put a guarantee on it,
and then,
and then sell that mortgage to somebody else.
So just like you have one bond,
one,
one commercial building,
uh,
you know,
offered through bonds.
You also had won a house then guaranteed and offered a one mortgage for one
house,
then guaranteed and offered for sale.
These firms also began to pull these mortgages and he pulled together a hundred
or so of these mortgages are a thousand of these mortgages,
put a guarantee on them,
and then sell those,
uh,
those,
pooled claims out,
uh,
as bonds.
So this picture represents not just those commercial bonds that I showed you,
but also residential securities.
And you can see what happened is that they were coming along doing fine,
small part of the business.
And then in the 20s,
both of them picked up dramatically.
As a matter of fact,
the first world war was an important hinge point in the history of this
particular kinds of financial innovation.
Um,
the first world war was the first us more that was financed by massive issues
of,
uh,
of a war bonds.
And it became a pit.
You patriotic duty to buy more bonds to finance the,
the effort.
When the war was over and those bonds were,
we're,
uh,
were reclaimed by the government.
They were paid off by the government.
People had been used to owning securities,
a whole operation to sell the securities had existed as sales.
Uh,
operation.
so then,
um,
uh,
the broker said,
what else are we going to sell?
And a real estate bonds became a really important,
uh,
new product.
So you can see this might have been driven by demand actually for investment
product in a,
in a marketing system that had grown,
um,
uh,
for savings bonds,
earlier,
you know,
during the war.
Nevertheless,
you can see this stuff really take off and uh,
and peak and around 19,
late twenties.
Okay.
Uh,
these,
that was cumulative.
This is just new,
uh,
new issues.
There you see the,
the,
uh,
the drop,
um,
around the crash time,
uh,
even more dramatically.
Okay.
Um,
this is a picture of,
uh,
the,
those plotting those number of new for commercial bar for commercial properties
against a new buildings.
And here we only took a look at new buildings that were 70 meters high or so.
So,
uh,
so,
so we're looking at really tall buildings.
Um,
this is a time period when,
uh,
the skyscrapers were,
was really born in the 19 1890s.
And,
uh,
really got going in the early part of the 20th century.
So a question that,
um,
that we began to ask ourselves is,
maybe the skyscraper was a response to the emergence of a new capital market for
fixed income securities.
Maybe the financing drove the desire for big buildings rather than the the other
way around.
I mean,
New York and other cities had existed for a long time without skyscrapers.
Um,
and there's a lot of interesting theory about how skyscrapers were a kind of a
result of changes in zoning laws in some places and so forth.
Um,
but if you think about it,
London did fine without skyscrapers for many years.
Paris,
London,
other great capitals of the world did fine without skyscrapers.
Why would you suddenly have these,
uh,
sort of immediate blossoming of skyscrapers war,
truly coincident with an emergence of a capital market and an ability to sell
these,
these bonds?
Um,
uh,
so,
um,
by the way,
how would,
is there any way you can think of testing that theory about which,
uh,
um,
if I,
if my theory was finance made skies,
Scott skyscrapers or finance led to big buildings,
how would you test that theory?
If you had some data
boy guy that was taking anybody?
I want to cold call on somebody,
but your chances of being cold called um,
yes back there.
That's okay.
Wait for the money.
I can hear you.
Yes.
And comparing how that was.
Yeah.
Um,
so look across country,
uh,
and Lacrosse section where you'd like to find conditions that,
that,
um,
maybe didn't have this,
uh,
financial explosion
capital markets.
Okay.
Does everybody know what endogeneity is?
A,
everybody who's an econ major and you're a senior or junior,
you probably know.
Okay.
Other than that,
you probably think it's some kind of horrible skin disease.
Um,
and dodge Djenne,
it means that,
um,
that the,
the factors that you're studying could actually be,
uh,
it can be some reverse causality going on or there could be some,
a,
a common on identified factor that could be driving both of them.
And you have to find some way of sorting this out.
Uh,
so the question is,
so the one way to do this is to find some independent,
um,
phenomena to observe.
That's what's being proposed.
Any other suggestions?
Um,
Pierson College,
I will
give you that.
It states
the number of skyscrapers like this,
and I would read through that.
Probably the first skyscrapers were not playing with these types of,
at least initially driving skyscraper construction.
Okay.
So,
um,
if you can find a skyscraper that was the first skyscraper was if you can show
that it wasn't financed by these bonds,
you could prove that it's possible to have skyscrapers without the financing.
So that's a,
that's a,
that's a way to test the basic proposition.
You know,
a,
it may be,
um,
may not,
you can prove that it's an unnecessary condition.
If you can find one example.
Okay.
One more idea.
Who's an SOM student?
We've got one here.
No,
uh,
you hear in them?
Yes.
Gray,
a charcoal,
a tee shirt.
Any idea
other than taking a survey,
looking at multiple cities and skyscrapers started to be built and when this
capital work developed,
uh,
I don't think I could really add anything else.
That's good.
Take a look.
Cross-Sectionally at the different cities,
see if they have maybe access to capital markets different,
different,
differently across the cities and see what the timing is.
That's a good idea.
Okay.
I'll tell you what we have been doing.
Um,
we figured that,
uh,
one interesting issue here is has to do with the size of the bond issue.
If you have a really,
um,
if you have a tiny building and you want to go to the public capital markets,
do you think an investment bank is gonna gonna give you the time of day?
Absolutely not.
Um,
there are basic,
uh,
issues of economies of scale that have to do with financing.
Uh,
so,
um,
so what we did is we said,
let's take a look at the size of the bond issue.
We also looked at the height of the building,
but the size of the bond issues,
the legitimate thing to look at and presuming that the,
the biggest bond issue,
the bigger the building.
And then we asked is the interest rate on the bond that is the,
uh,
the,
the rate at which the bond was issued,
was that lower or higher for bigger,
uh,
for,
for bigger buildings.
And what we found pretty strikingly is that the bigger the building,
the lower the yield,
the lower the cost of capital.
And so if you're thinking about,
if you're a developer and you've got a plot and you could build two small
buildings are one big building,
or you could finance it all at once or one at a time,
and you know that you're going to be able to have a lower cost of capital,
what are you going to do?
You're going to build one really big building.
So you can see,
you know,
finance has this potential maybe to possibly even distort the way that,
the way that the city's develop because of simple issues like cost of capital.
And,
uh,
those guys sitting around,
the,
uh,
toasting themselves that we saw in 1892,
the creation of that market for those securities may have had an influence on,
on the,
on the New York skyline,
uh,
during that time period.
Here's just a picture by the way,
of,
uh,
of the tall buildings in New York and when they were all constructed and you see
huge boom during this period and then along Malays during the middle of the
century,
during war time,
and then the market picked back up.
I'll tell you one sort of shocking thing to me is that the,
the residential mortgage backed security market completely disappeared in the
30s.
And that commercial,
a one building,
one bond market completely disappeared at least by 1940 or so.
I mean,
there's still bonds that may exist when I see disappeared.
They stopped new issues and you couldn't easily trade these things.
They didn't change hands.
So there are bonds that are still paying out.
I have a,
a friend whose mother,
whose family has some securities that were used to build the empire state
building.
They're still paying them money and they're proud to own these things.
But these are the fossils of the,
uh,
of the financial world.
So what you had is this extraordinary period of innovation in,
in,
in financing of real estate.
Um,
the shift in the way that people were able to access mortgage money and the,
and the change in the way that developers thought about how they would build
buildings and all of a,
came to a grinding horrible.
And,
uh,
as a result of the Great Depression,
did that market caused the crash or was it a w w w was,
was did the fallout from the crash destroy that market?
That's the question we're asking ourselves today,
right?
We're saying,
well,
subprime obviously caused the big problem that we're in.
And,
um,
so,
uh,
the foolish bankers,
a idiots at want to do,
own their own home and were bullying to borrow to the hilt,
this horrible evil brew of,
uh,
of,
people that,
uh,
couldn't plan ahead and bankers that were willing to give them a,
give them enough rope that they can hang themselves as sort of the theme,
the drum beat.
We're hearing,
you know,
you,
you sort of wonder maybe that the,
the mortgage market is a,
um,
is a casualty rather than a,
a,
a cause of this crash.
Yeah.
So a dog is giving you some readings,
um,
that,
uh,
kind of a hard,
reading to slog through.
But,
um,
because,
uh,
although if you're as,
again,
if you're an econ major,
you should be able to snap your way right through this thing cause it's got a
bunch of regressions and tables and,
and uh,
and plots.
But let me just tell you a little bit about the idea of this paper.
I'm doing it with a,
with a Liang Pang who was,
um,
a colleague of mine.
He's now at Colorado.
Um,
and Jackie Yen,
who's a doctoral student at Yale and Jackie,
um,
uh,
is studying to be a finance professor,
but she also,
uh,
worked in,
Wall Street for quite some time and knows a lot about,
uh,
about these capital markets,
particularly about mortgage data.
And the question we're asking is a simple one,
like many scholars right now,
we want to try and help,
uh,
the world,
understand what the causes of this crisis are.
But we're in a position that we don't,
I'm not quite sure I know what the causes are.
And so the way that we're dealing with that is we're gathering some data and
we're looking at it and putting questions to this data.
Um,
the data that we got or housing indexes,
those come from Bob Schiller,
uh,
and chip case,
who developed these when I was a graduate student here,
Bob and chip case had just started building these indexes of housing.
Um,
and so,
uh,
we really have data going back.
Uh,
I think they stretch back their data start from about,
well,
late eighties or so.
And what they do is they take sales of housing,
they take houses that had been sold twice in a given city and they get thousands
of those and you can sort of figure out what's the best measure of return to
explain all of those repeated sales.
So it's actually transactions based measures of housing.
Uh,
we've got those for all the,
the city,
the big cities in the country and metropolitan statistical areas about 320 or
330 of these.
Then we have some additional city level information we can compare that to.
Then we've got,
um,
mortgage issuance by city.
And finally,
this is pretty amazing.
For one year,
for 2006,
we took all the mortgages that were issued in the entire country and we have a
detailed data about those mortgages.
Uh,
so we figured somewhere buried in this data,
we're going to be able to get some sense of what,
what the problem was.
Okay.
Here's a chart
on this axis is past price growth from 1999 to 2005,
end of 2005.
So what did we do?
We took each one of those cities.
We look at that index that Bob Schiller had created and we said,
um,
we just plotted the total growth that that index had undergone over the period
over the,
over the two thousands up through 2005.
So we wanted to look at the hot markets,
which are the really hot markets,
which ones had really grown a lot.
And you could see some of them are grown by almost a factor of three Las Vegas.
Uh,
there are parts of California and Nevada and Florida that were just off the
charts having grown like an amazing amount.
And by the way,
there are a lot of cities where there wasn't much growth at all.
The whole cluster here of cities that had grown by a factor of,
well,
they'd grown 30%,
but that was over a long length of time.
They're probably growing at less than 10% per year.
Well,
10% per year over this time period was actually a pretty good investment.
When you think about it,
the stock market was doing terribly.
We just got off this horrible bender from the tech bubble.
People said,
stocks are terrible.
I don't want to invest in them anymore.
Bonds were decent investment,
but there were people really wondering,
what are we going to put my money in?
And a lot of people thought,
you know,
housing,
although a modest growth in many of these cities,
housing might not be such a bad thing.
You think about it.
If you're sitting in the year 2000 having just been burned by the tech bubble,
you know,
the saying where,
how am I going to save for myself and my family?
You know,
why not put your money in your house?
At least you can watch the asset.
You can take care of it,
you can improve it.
Granted,
you have to be taxes on it and you have to fix it up and uh,
it's not very liquid.
Okay.
But you balance these things off.
It might be,
you know,
it,
it was the new asset class of the era.
It was a idea.
It was not a speculative asset.
It was a savings related acid.
Okay.
How about this other access subprime approvals in 2006,
uh,
the log of the dollar amount in thousands,
we looked at all of these,
uh,
we looked at the rate CD by city of subprime approvals.
That is people that had applied for a subprime mortgage and then,
um,
being approved for a been approved a subprime mortgage means you don't qualify
to get a prime mortgage.
To qualify for a prime mortgage,
you have to have steady source of income,
you have to have a good credit rating.
Um,
there has to be a good loan to value ratio.
That means you don't ask trying to borrow too much.
You have to have a house that is appraised in such a way that the loan to value
ratio is a legitimate measure that some of the bank can trust.
If you're not in that circumstance,
then you're us in sub world of subprime.
Okay.
So what we see here is sub prime approvals were more frequent in markets where
the prices had gone up.
Why would that be
okay.
I'll ask you this as a general question.
Why would you expect
that?
Yes.
Yeah.
Okay.
Yeah,
this sounds like endogeneity.
That's good.
Um,
people,
uh,
the houses would go up too fast.
They,
the normal loan,
they can't,
they can't get a normal loan to buy a house.
They might have been able to buy 10 years ago with a prime loan.
So therefore you've got a necessity of more demand,
uh,
for subprime loans.
These are approvals though.
That means the bankers had to say yes.
Okay.
So bankers had to go along with this,
uh,
to,
to get this graph.
Yeah.
Crisis
just score upwards.
So people in general just start eating more risks and financial institutions
which grabbed the subprime loans also become overly optimistic.
They are to be led,
prices have to go up and they feel that the real value passive increase.
That sounds like,
it sounds like your rational exuberance.
Okay.
Um,
so,
um,
it's easy to say that they're irrational.
It's harder to say that they're rational.
Okay.
It'd be nice to know if,
uh,
um,
first of all,
Bob Schiller is a good friend of mine and uh,
I've,
I love his book and I love his wonderful intuition about when the cart is going
off the track a and he's tends to be right.
So it's hard to deny that irrational exuberance is behind a lot of the big
messes we're in.
Um,
however,
as an economist you sort of want to see how much you can get with the,
with the rational stories first and then have the remainder be the,
the exuberant.
So we're going to push on that a little bit.
Yeah.
Interpret this.
Sorry.
I
interpret this to try to,
as prices of asset values are going up and separate approvals are going at the
same time,
I think to strategize to be increasing and leveraged this,
that's the only way to fill the gap.
You're not saying that so prime incomes are going up,
but you're saying the approvals are going up,
so something has to fill that gap.
Purchase prices,
that means they're being more heavily leveraged.
Yeah.
I think that there's some evidence,
a consistent with your,
with your observation,
it's amazing how much you can get off staring at a graph like that because
buried behind it or a whole bunch of decisions by individuals applying and by
bankers.
Um,
uh,
deciding,
I'm going to show you a picture of just from one city.
This is from a Seattle.
And what we've done here is we've gone from 2006.
Um,
what we've done is we've said,
let's extrapolate the housing price from two in 2006.
Let's extrapolate it and then use some econometrics to figure out how far down
we think it could go and how far up it could go.
Those are those two lines there.
Um,
and then there's a wiggly line which shows you exactly what housing prices did.
and so,
uh,
actually I'm going to show you some more in just a second when I want you to
understand the geography of this first.
Um,
these are confidence bands.
And if you're thinking,
if you're a banker and you're going to make a loan,
the first thing you want to know is,
is this loan devalue ratio gonna um,
change a lot over the time period of loan,
a lot of subprime loans sort of reset after three years and so forth.
You'd like to have some confidence or at least know how far down the value could
go so that,
you know,
cause you're worried about the loan value being higher than the loan being
higher than the,
than the house value that's called underwater.
So you're worried about the value of the asset.
Bless you.
So this picture is really couldn't confidence bounds on the value of the asset.
And um,
what this is saying is that in 2006,
if you just extrapolated the prices from that time,
you'd get a kind of a flat line and then you didn't,
you wouldn't find any reason to expect that over the next three years or prices
could drop more than,
than 20% or so.
So,
uh,
only one time out of 20,
would you get a shock?
More than 20%?
Oops.
How would you get that?
Oops,
here we are.
Now here's a hole here,
a whole bunch of these,
uh,
the same exercise and I'll tell you a little bit about the exercise.
Here's where the econometrics comes in.
We take those indexes that chiller gave us for all the different cities,
these major cities,
and then we did it.
Um,
we did something that any red blooded econometrician would do.
We did an auto regression,
which says a that past growth,
uh,
estimates relationship to him,
past growth and future growth.
And what you see from all of these housing indexes is that past trends seem to
be followed.
Uh,
there seems to be on a huge amount of momentum and inertia in these,
these movements of these markets,
even when they're going down,
once they start,
here's a,
here's a Minneapolis,
it was going up like this incredible auto correlation and past trends.
And then of course,
once it starts going down,
it just keeps going down.
This is not a random walk.
Housing doesn't follow random walk by any stretch of the imagination.
It's very,
very predictable.
You could predict,
the models tell you that you could predict the housing prices with a huge degree
of confidence for three years out,
just given about 20 or 20,
you know,
15 or 20 years worth of,
of,
of past data.
So,
uh,
so all of these pictures show you that for each city there is a line,
which is the past price increase.
That's a not Las Vegas went up like crazy at one point.
Then there are the two confidence bands,
then there's the orange bar saying,
what do we expect the PR the price trend to be?
But it's not the expectation that's so important.
It's this lower bound.
How bad can it get if you're a banker?
That's the thing.
It tells you,
you know,
uh,
is this loan going to be a disaster?
And every single one of these cities,
virtually the actual price just plunged right through the,
the bankers confidence bands.
So,
uh,
if you've got a model that's an,
an econometric model that's based on past price trends and you ran that model in
2006,
you wouldn't have been able to predict any of this crash.
You would have felt pretty confident that when you are writing those mortgages,
even the,
even the subprime mortgage that,
uh,
that those were good bonds,
tubs,
a good loan,
you know,
a subprime loan doesn't mean that the house is bad.
It just means that the lender is bad.
It's a subprime borrowers bad.
The,
it's a subprime borrower,
not a subprime house.
So you say,
look,
what's the worst that could happen?
My borrower can't.
Uh,
we get into some trouble.
My borrower can't make the payments on the house,
then the bank has to repossess the house.
But if the house price isn't going to move much,
then what the heck?
We'll just turn around and sell the house.
So we've got good collateral.
Um,
and,
and we all know what happened.
Uh,
that model turned out though that econometric model turned out to be complete a
disaster.
Okay.
Actually one more point on this.
What do you need for an econometric model
aside from a econometrics textbook?
Sas I use are,
I did this and this was a program called our data.
Some people use that.
What else do you need to run an econometric model?
Yeah,
this isn't a trick question.
Um,
you have a blue scarf on.
What do you need to run them to estimate a model like this data.
Okay.
You need data.
And um,
so the data come from Robert Shiller and the fact is,
unless you have those housing indexes,
you can't run this model.
The irony of these indexes is that although they opened a world to us of what
housing prices do,
they also made econometrician is believed that they could estimate the risk
associated with the housing.
Before we had those indexes,
we couldn't do any prediction.
We couldn't do any of this sophisticated mathematical calculations.
And we couldn't walk into a,
to uh,
uh,
to the president of the bank and say,
look,
we've done a value at risk calculation using these fantastic indexes that tell
us that the probability of us losing more than 20% of,
of our capital.
Um,
it,
it is a 0.005,
you couldn't do it suddenly with this data,
a little bit of information.
It's a really dangerous thing when you,
you put it in front of somebody that knows how to crank through a regression.
And,
uh,
so it's a terrible thing to blame Bob Shiller,
the person that forecast this crash to blame him on the other hand for providing
the,
the matches,
the law people to burn down the house who was a failure of models,
but you can't run the models without the data.
Okay.
I'll just give you a little bit more flavor for what we do.
We run a whole bunch of regressions,
we're looking for relationships,
but mainly what we do is we divide things up into world of the demand side for,
for loans and the supply side for loans.
And what we want to ask is,
was it a stupid or avaricious banker that drove the crash or was it the stupid
or an or an average this homeowner borrower that drove the crash neither or
both.
Okay.
And,
uh,
here we have subprime mortgages and prime mortgages.
And so,
um,
roughly when we look at relationships,
here's what we find
we find for both subprime and prime,
the numbers of,
uh,
applications and measured by dollars and numbers of applications.
We're increasing in those home prices.
So when the home price goes up,
you make your forecast of what the worst scenario might be.
And if you had a positive trend,
you would think that,
um,
you know,
uh,
lenders would be more comfortable that what the bottom line,
that they'd be able to get their money out.
And so Mike Borrowers,
if they think,
hey,
look,
I'm buying a house.
I'm putting every dime,
dime I have into it,
but the trends look pretty good.
I should be able to get my money out the other end.
Um,
then you ought to see a positive relationship between past price increases and,
um,
applications.
Uh,
however,
what you want to slice it.
Somebody mentioned,
you mentioned leverage.
Okay.
Exactly.
That's exactly what happened.
Uh,
uh,
there was a greater loan to income,
requests for,
um,
higher leverage requests for both of those two people actually also tended to,
this is loaned income,
a measure of leverage,
not loan to value,
uh,
the loan to value actually also the value to loan when up.
Why is that people felt comfortable putting more of their own money into houses
and then people bought more expensive houses.
But the indoctrinate of the issue,
who mentioned that that was a really important point there.
There were more expensive houses,
so that was inevitable.
Okay,
so where people being foolish?
Well,
that's a hard thing to say.
They looked at at it as a savings opportunity.
You could say this was,
uh,
this was a crisis driven by over too much demand for savings.
It's just that it didn't save and just at the savings vehicle was the house.
Um,
we're the irrationally exuberant.
Well,
if you look at those trends,
maybe I would have been fooled by the same trend as well.
How about on the banker's side?
Now the banker's job is to say no.
Okay,
so to reject loans.
And what do we find here now?
The weirdest thing that we completely,
the completely shocked us is that approvals didn't really,
the rate of approvals for subprime once we control for a lot of things didn't
change as much as that we had expected.
And in fact the rate for approvals for prime actually went down,
which is strange.
That means bankers were getting tougher.
Well are only getting tougher because the demands were,
we're increasing.
Okay.
So,
um,
you have to look at this as the environment was changing because the,
the,
the demand for loans was increasing a lot,
but uh,
so that,
so that their,
their,
their approval rates were actually going down,
but it really doesn't look like
that doesn't look like irrational exuberance on the banker's part,
um,
for prime loans.
Um,
and mostly on the prime side,
bankers to appear to be behaving really pretty rationally.
Um,
less so on the,
on the,
on the subprime side.
So,
uh,
the,
loan to income ratio that was going up,
um,
uh,
the value to loan ratio was going down.
In other words,
people were having to put up there the less of their own cash to own the home
and people were having to,
um,
uh,
people were getting a higher loans with lower incomes.
So if anything,
I think what we're beginning to convince ourselves using this loan data that the
subprime market and the prime market were to kind of slightly disjointed markets
with a different decision processes.
It in operation,
both sides had securitization going on.
Um,
and um,
and uh,
we have an attack the question of whether securitizer Bible loans were driving
all of this,
but other people have been,
have been asking that question.
Okay.
So,
um,
uh,
we certainly found evidence of high of increase increasing,
um,
uh,
demand,
in prices.
So it could be the people chasing after chasing the trends.
Um,
but it could be also that,
uh,
the expectation of the,
of the,
uh,
of the liquidation value of the house was going up and made them feel safer
about the borrowing
a,
the riskiness of mortgage applications is increasing and past price,
everybody wants to buy more expensive homes.
Um,
but,
um,
uh,
that we documented and as I mentioned,
there's this disjunction between the,
the two.
So that's sort of a kind of a flavor for how a professor and some graduate
students look at the crisis you've been reading Posner,
um,
uh,
and um,
you see how somebody tries to put the whole thing together.
Well,
our,
our goal was to kind of deconstruct it.
Let me see if this,
well that's just the kind of more documentary evidence of what I was talking
about.
Um,
and uh,
um,
I don't know.
I've looked at history,
been interested in that and uh,
looked at current data.
So,
um,
without,
uh,
I don't know if we have time for questions or not,
but yeah,
I think there's time for a water
back there.
Notre Dame,
on one of your previous slide I mentioned that the side,
it seemed
to be almost constraint and you seem to attribute read that to I guess
potentially greater responsibility on the part of the bankers and not approval
increased in a low number of applications.
And I was wondering if you think that that is the case or if there's evidence
that it could just be that there was a,
a constraint on the supply where banks just were not able to issue more loans
due to capital requirements or other financial regulation.
The beautiful part about this work is that we're taking,
as given that people,
everybody,
the banks and the borrowers are operating in their own best interests.
Uh,
so that we're,
we're looking at this as sort of an equilibrium outcome where they've taken into
account the potential for the capital constraints and what have you.
So that negative coefficient actually,
um,
you'll see it here,
uh,
this negative coefficient on approvals for a prime versus subprime.
Um,
I,
my tone of voice may have led you to believe that I thought that was a foolish
thing.
It's certainly no evidence that it's foolish of all,
uh,
at all.
Um,
but it's,
it's an interesting puzzle.
I mean,
we expected to see everybody lifting the flood gates and,
and,
and make writing all these loans.
And the,
the notion that the,
the,
the prime a lenders we're actually clamping down suggests that they were
exercising a,
some,
you know,
judgment about quality of loan that resulted in this net negative.
Right.
One last question here.
Yes.
So on the same slide
is the same slide.
You also implied that the uh,
the supply side,
the bankers were,
we're not accepting these overleveraged,
uh,
mortgage applications as much as you would expect,
but,
but does your research indicate anything about how over leverage the banks were
themselves in how much capital,
you know,
they were taking out of the market?
Um,
so the cow,
the question you're asking,
asking really implies,
uh,
a point of view about,
um,
uh,
bank capital requirements.
Um,
and certainly I just use the data that I showed you so we didn't use that.
Uh,
any information,
as you know,
this is a big spider web of different relationships that scales all the way up
to the role,
the government and the role of capital requirements and regulators.
We just didn't,
we didn't pay attention to all of that.
Our job is not to put thing together,
but t two s to see if we can find certain pieces that help us understand whether
decisions were good or bad.
Max Roach,
a terrific.